hello recognition I'm drink hello
education I'm done we're gonna watch the
trailer today for okay ja yeah I'm not
sure how to pronounce this word I'm sure
we all hear it in the trailer at some
point it was like to deploy so what is
needed a miracle and then we got well
what is that this beautiful and special
little creature the evolution in the
livestock industry but our super foods
will not only be seeing a beautiful
super table also leave a minimal
footprint on the environment who seem
less feed and produce less excretion and
most importantly they need to taste
[ __ ] good what
[Music]
that was cleverly done vision taste
lesson we are animators our plan is to
expose a random rescue function bring
her back to you 10 years and firing mama
comes with a plausible sweet million
what happened destroy you should know
the situation
[Music]
[Music]
Wow this just like a night of great
trailers or something from having a turn
on a good day for trailers days you
react to treasure town oh you have my
check right Nate from there whoa-oh
you know I've always comment came in to
go watch this trailer you are up the
source is battlin I just like what is
what is this groovy yeah I never I had
no idea what we were gonna do and then
it start playing like oh it's like one
of those like cute family films Yeah
right like oh this is gonna be like
weirdly adorable yeah something like
that right when it said it most
importantly they need to fight in case
could the whole thing switch and there's
a kept going my jaw was dropped for a
little bit of it like a while actually
because I was I was in just expecting
that cuz Ned if from what this is clever
trailer because the whole point of is to
latch on to the main characters emotions
this is an animal with its soul with a
spirit and it's her best friend and
there's no way she's gonna let her best
friend die and then when you're watching
your jnanis with your cute animal this
is awesome this is like this is really a
really bonded with the human and welcome
I'll I'll just gets more and more cities
ya know like it's almost like it's aids
to the background even if you hadn't
picked it up yet even if you hadn't just
if you you're just hearing the words and
seeing the eyes and not find them
together that [ __ ] in the minute I wake
you up wait what everybody is playing a
character in this tool and a nose like a
badass for a change
yeah now drivers the better called Anna
looks like the most like himself in this
trail and oddly enough II it's like the
biggest stretches oh you just look like
a competent guy I was playing like
weirdos and it's first time
could be aware of again he looks cool
guys are cool or weird dad and I imitate
with a jake gyllenhaal yeah tell me
swing on Amanda's wedding choosing
snowpiercer right til it's mine ah what
she added something about right yeah
Chris Chris Evans I'm sure Chris
Hemsworth was not in that movie so dog
red Oh down the duct today is not the
day to get flabbergasted my trick is the
second trailer in a row now are
logically I'm I'm so surprised by how
great of a trailer that was oh yeah man
this might be the best Netflix original
trailer at least that I've seen I can't
say the movie but in terms of trailers
this might be the best one I've seen
other than have a highly cool MCU show
or something yeah I don't know I always
got a wonder about these because it's
like Netflix right now it seems like
they have pretty decent judgement and
like when they put their name on
something it usually turns out to be
interesting if if not you know great
yeah yeah I could take Gyllenhaal to do
with the glasses you gonna have today
one point heading that is they called
super pig a super pig will not only be
big and beautiful
I'm sure the blunt term I look it looks
like an interesting type of allegory for
animal rights be of exterior soap yeah
it kind of it kind of plays on that a
little bit well yeah yeah I mean at
least the whole you know sort of like
this is an animal with the life in them
and it's alive and it is it's here the
experiencing too but also we're going to
put it in a factoring you guys are going
to eat it yeah but it also looks like
intense and exciting and adventurous and
yeah it's a really cool action visual
style and there comes when it looks like
a Gris she looks more than just I'm CEO
corporate cheering up the scenery he
didn't even have that one moment in her
band where she's like sitting in a chair
look she was crying a bit about how
everything's going wrong right now yeah
but Steven Yeun and thank God he's back
yeah and guts and gods and goddesses
changing coach Aaron Carlo Esposito yeah
Esposito's I know that's smelling more
than I know
the name there's a whole bunch of actors
in this film and I think that's just a
perfect enough trailer right there to
hook me I don't really need to see more
than that
the acting looks really good the visuals
look really good and while it seems to
have inspiration of being like an
allegory for animal rights it weirdly
doesn't feel like a preachy kind of
movie to me well that's the thing is all
the elements in this this is this
trailer seems like it's good enough at
suggesting you a lot of things and not
telling you anything there's such a
specific type of world and not
not-too-distant future type of scenario
going on yeah I mean I'm sure there's
going to be some kind of contemplation
of animal rights and and the way we
interact with animals but I'm sure that
will also be kind of prism akin a movie
like this like it it looks like there's
probably a lot of stuff going on and I
hope there's a lot going on - the house
looks like is interested in making
interesting stuff well the thing about
the animal rights people the people who
like we love Angela with Paul Dano says
or his line is by Hamill right oh yeah
they're more than just like they're not
just protesting or something you know
like here to do it badass badass - Ewan
- it for us to protect this animal you
know there's not doing like
stereotypical like oh yeah but yeah yeah
yeah exactly that so that's what makes
it look a lot different - or I don't
feel like I'm going in to watch a
preachy kind of film I feel like I'm
just going to go and watch the specific
tale be told so no that's a word I feel
like you can use for it a tale yeah meat
play on words because this has a table
ta il it does use an animal like a
modern it definitely is a fantasy
element yeah it's fantasy sci-fi yeah
it's a good we figure out what the
jogger is what talking about it a little
more alright alright yeah that was one
hell of a trailer I'm very intrigued by
this I got to see some more bunk
jin-ho's movies because I've heard great
things about snowpiercer and then
there's a beer sir well yeah but I'm
just thing as I'm sure I'm aware of
other movies
Juno's me like you know their app
because I thought up Korean filmmaker
Lee's yeah yeah and like that's not a
cinema categorized in my know a ton
about so I know like a few names in a
handful of movies I don't know which one
quite corresponds to yeah but yeah this
is definitely pulling me in my god would
love to invest in checking out some more
of these going soon
man I got j-jim all the play known as to
play like a I love widgets Hera either
love when Jake Gyllenhaal plays like who
really goes all out like mannerisms and
look at love I love that one Jake
Gyllenhaal does like as much as I wanted
to see like I didn't see any of that
kind of Jake Gyllenhaal the trigger your
great film and whoever the the girl is
the little girl you might get a future
star here it's a good year for little
girls kicking ass in the movie hell yeah
have a good time no alcohol required
alrighty then alright oh hey guys you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell as well Det
John Humphrey on Instagram and Twitter
social media manager of Blum house comm
go check out our patreon we have a lot
of exclusive perks on there anything you
guys pleasure go to help support the
channel keep this channel running right
now
really appreciate it and flexing other
rewards I think are actually pretty
freaking sweet we may believe them to be
like ugly plastic like yeah I think it's
actually fun yeah I got this time
milling on yeah we're gonna [ __ ] go
it off it's just a little piece of
confetti at everyone till you get some
good money if you want to know if it's
worth it is that someone who's a part of
the patreon and then shoot them iMessage
and see if they don't if they are
enjoying it get it get work from that no
take our word for it
I love God and all the other Bible
creatures as well thanks for watching
much appreciate me how much what that's
not three no it's a tie anyhow
I'll just short porch